لحظات استثنائيه وليله ماسيه عاشتها
الرياض امس خلال حفل توزيع جوائز صناع
الترفيه جوي وورز 20 22 والحفل اللي اقيم
برعايه هيئه الترفيه ممثله برئيسها تركي
ال الشيخ واللي ضمن مجموعه كبيره من نجوم
الوطن العربي والعالم في مجالات السينما
والغناء والرياضه والسوشيال ميديا شاهد
هذا الحفل تفاعل كبير من النجوم اللي كان
الفرح والسعاده بجمعتهم في الرياض عنوانهم
العريض لهذه الليله
[موسيقى]
طبعا مثل ما قلت لكم حفل جوائز صناعه
الثالثه من خلاله تكريم عدد كبير من
النجوم والفنانين والمؤثرين بجوائز في
مجالات التلفزيون والسينما والرياضه
والموسيقى بالاضافه لبعض الوجوه الجديده
في تلك الفئات دعما للمواهب الشابه
وتحفيزا لهم وتميز الحفل هذه السنه بتقديم
جوائز فخريه وفي منها تم تقديمها لاول مره
وكرم خلال رئيس هيئه الترفيه تركي ال
الشيخ عدد من النجوم العرب والاجانب فحصل
الشيخ وليد ال ابراهيم رئيس مجلس اداره ام
بي سي على الجائزه الماسيه وفازت الفنانه
العالميه صوفيا بجائزه شخصيه العام
بالاضافه لفوز كل من الفنان راشد الماجد
الفنان
احمد حلمي ومنى زكي محمد منير حياه الفهد
سعد عبد الله نوال وسالم الهندي رئيس
التنفيذي لشركه روتانا كلهم
الفخريه هذه جائزه مميزه نقدمها لاول مره
جوي الماسيه لان لشخصيه ماسيه من بلد
الحبيب تفضل شيخ وليد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تحديث
ما الجيبسون
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اميتاب باتشان
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وغير الاجواء الجميله اللي ميزت الحفل ففي
مشهد كان لافت في الحفل كمان هو حضور
اللاعب اشرف حكيمي الي خطف الاضواء
كالعاده مع والدته وفاز بجائزه افضل رياضي
عربي
اشرف حكيم
تعالي تعالي معه
[موسيقى]
اشرف حكيمي
تعالي تعالي معه
[موسيقى]
وكمان من بين الحضور لفتت الانظار جورجينا
رودريغيز صديقه النجم البرتغالي كريستيانو
رونالدو اللي شاركت في اول الفعاليه لها
وقدمت جائزه افضل لاعب رياضيه وكانت شاركت
صوره كمان لاطلالتها من الحفل وشكرت كل
الناس على محبتها وعبرتك كمان عن محبتها
للسعوديه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اريد فيميل اصلي
السعوديه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]